put down your latest copy of Bearskin
magazine why are all these Pages stuck
together uh we have the latest episode
of The Last of Us sponsored by Chef
Boyardee I do love Chef Boyardee though
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into the episode comparing it to
the game and taking a look at some of
the details you may have missed but
before we begin make sure to infect that
like And subscribe button because I may
not cover everything you watch but when
I do it's fantastic we last Saw Joel and
Ellie leaving Bill and franks in Lincoln
Massachusetts and we last saw me
crumpled in a pool of my own tears
they've taken Bill's blue truck the same
one from the game with one glaring
difference no Bill yes in the game
version they actually take Bill to the
edge of town before he gives them a
loving parting present of a siphon
something the show will not add as we'll
later see Joel blowing harder than the
Leafs during the playoffs Ellie is doing
her best Travis Bickle in the bathroom
of a rundown gas station
at the end of episode 3 we saw her hide
a handgun the same one Frank stashed
away in the drawer of the living room
remember all the way back in episode 2
she's been wanting a gun of her own even
admiring the guns Joel has but it seems
as though she doesn't have much
experience with him even though she'll
later tell Joel she's had some fedra
basic training she drops around
meticulously examines a bullet and even
smells the gun for her this is a whole
experience of course Joel does not know
she has this secret gun and as we'll
find out later in the episode Ellie
breaks one of Joel's three rules rule
three
you do what I say when I say it more on
that in a bit Joel and Ellie are on
their way to Kansas City in the game
it's actually Pittsburgh there are a few
reasons Craig Mason and Neil druckman
may have made this change one Kansas
City is a lot farther away from
Pittsburgh allowing more time to pass
for Ellie and Joel to bond two Kansas
City looks and feels more like Calgary
where they shot the show rather than
Pittsburgh and three it makes for a less
dramatic Gap going all the way from
Pittsburgh to the game's next large
Locale Wyoming either way a lot of the
core story doesn't change Joel and Ellie
need to siphon gas every hour or so
since it's been 20 years and most of the
gas has broken down into almost water
but what I found particularly sad here
was when Ellie asked Joel where he
traveled to when he had a full tank of
gas that could take him nearly anywhere
he responds pretty much nowhere Joe like
many of us have and would took this
pre-pandemic life for granted in episode
3 we see how Ellie gets so excited at
the prospect of flying in a plane
something Jewel merely shrugs off what
we find is mundane Ellie finds fantastic
and get ready for the most terrible puns
in the world I hope to God this will
Livingston character didn't make it he's
the author of no pun intended and no pun
intended Volume 2 the second being a
book given to Ellie by her friend Riley
in the Left Behind DLC I heard two
peanuts walked into a park
one was assaulted
we haven't met Riley yet but we know
from the season trailer that she does
make an appearance even Marlene mentions
her in episode 1. was Riley a terrorist
I won't delve too much into their
relationship at this point but the two
were friends and it seems as though
Ellie keeps this book as a reminder of
her you can even see the book in Ellie's
home in Jackson in The Last of Us Part
Two almost all the puns from the show
are directly lifted from the game what
did the mermaid wear to her math class
I'm Alex you bra what did the mermaid
wear to her math class what
an algebra kill me now the pileup of
cars here suggest they were waiting for
gas that never came however Joel also
mentions the military crafted these huge
snowplow type trucks that would push
Vehicles out of the way to make room for
military convoys I also love how their
car is one of the only colorful things
in this shot in the top right of the
screen where they came from is it dark
and stormy while the left side is bright
and sunny it makes me think of the
Firefly slogan when you're lost in the
darkness look for the light Ellie
remarks that she'd one day want to see a
tank getting her wish a few hours later
as they pass a graveyard of broken down
military vehicles I enjoyed the
stockpile of canned food beside her
taken from Bill and franks I'm sure a 20
year old can of Chef Boyardee is
somewhere in there that will see them
enjoy later on in the back Ellie finds a
tape of Hank Williams singles which
plays a song titled alone and forsaken
this is the same song that played in the
season trailer it mentions a man's loss
of a woman leaving him alone and
forsaken which for Joel could symbolize
Tess or his daughter Sarah in the game a
different Hank Williams song plays at
this exact point with an equally
tongue-in-cheek title I'll never get out
of this world alive Ellie also finds
some leftovers from Bill and Frank in
the game it's a magazine called hard man
while in the show it's bare skin I guess
they can't get enough of the puns this
episode and the attention to detail is
astonishing with both versions having
this Forest advertisement on the back
how the hell
the hell wrong with that thing get rid
of in both versions Ellie throws the
magazine out the window
what's up
we get a few shots of the crumbling
Countryside now turned Wasteland an
abandoned roller coaster and Bill's
favorite restaurant and this is not an
Arby's of note is this giant Railway
which is the Lethbridge viaduct in
Alberta completed in 1909 it's the
world's longest and highest steel rail
Trestle and unlike the show about 12
trains cross it per day I also liked
Ellie saying she's not tired than
immediately cutting to her asleep a gag
taken directly from the game with the
sun setting Joel and Ellie parked their
truck in the forest safe from the side
of the road Joel believes the seclusion
of the forest will keep them safe from
clickers but more importantly Raiders
and Hunters hence they don't light a
fire Ellie here eats faster than Matt
Stoney and the plan is to drive all day
and night tomorrow and reach Wyoming by
next morning the two go to bed and Bill
and Frank's sleeping bags and Ellie
recites a pun that's also found in the
game what is scare go get an award
because he was outstanding in his field
although in the game version Joel
doesn't know the answer all right
because he was outstanding in his field
Joel tries to ease Ellie's fears saying
that no one is going to find them but
even he doesn't quite believe this as he
clutches his gun and instead of sleeping
watches over her during the night Ellie
wakes up to the smell of coffee
something that would be seen as a luxury
in the Boston qz luckily Bill had a nice
Supply in the game Joel sure does like
his coffee
go to coffee shops a lot I did
I really miss golfing Joel and Ellie are
currently on the I-76 a stretch of
Interstate that goes east and west
between Ohio and New Jersey the plan is
to hit the I-70 and continue Westward
all the way to Kansas City their final
destination is Wyoming the last known
location of Joel's brother Tommy if you
remember back in episode 1 we learned
from the radio operator his last message
came from a tower somewhere in the state
because he was a former Firefly he may
know more about these secret Firefly
bases filled with doctors that he can
take Ellie to Ellie asked Joel why Tommy
isn't with him Tommy is what Joel calls
a joiner with dreams of joining the Army
straight out of high school this is
likely why we see this Army bumper
sticker on the back of his truck in
episode one but Tommy became
disillusioned after his tour in Desert
Storm joining the Army didn't make him
feel like a hero at all and after the
pandemic Tommy convinces Joel to join
him in a group making their way up to
Boston and the only real reason Joel
joined him was to keep an eye on him yet
another example people of Joel being
this protector type character it was
with this group that they met Tess and
for a time this life worked for them
that is until Tommy met Marlene Marlene
convinced Tommy that he could make a
difference if he were to join the
fireflies just like the Army convinced
him he could make a difference with them
so he left Joel and went out on his own
I dreamed him fireflies all of them
delusional so Joel being the big brother
he is is in search of him that
protective Instinct taking over but
perhaps the most important conversation
Joel and Ellie have is over family keep
going for family
about it I'm not family no
your cargo we've seen how Joel bottles
his emotions and by referring to elia's
Cargo it's one of several ways he
protects himself from getting hurt
losing cargo is a lot less painful than
losing a family member but as we go
through the season and their bond grows
expect that to change the road through
Kansas City is blocked and I love the
added bonus of skeletons waiting in
their cars it reminded me a lot of
getting stuck in traffic in La instead
of taking the long route around the city
Joel decides to take the next ramp which
means having to go through the city
itself again the attention to detail as
we Traverse the barren streets of Kansas
City is amazing I especially love the
theater which plays underworld and
Matchstick Men two films which came out
in 2003 the year the pandemic started
and shout out to Radio Shack rest in
peace in the game there's a large
sequence that takes place at the Grand
Hotel but this was shifted to episode 2
Boston in the show oh I'll be checking
in for one night and I would like your
finest Suite please yes sir I would like
your finest Suite please you are a weird
kid you're a weird kid there's also a
brief scene that takes place outside
ephedra military prep school this is the
same type of school Ellie went to in
Boston in the American dream Comics
along the streets are these piles of
bones in the game Joel and Ellie come
across Summoner Mark oh
I don't think these guys were
it's a hint at the new enemies to come
they find the Kansas City qz with the
doors completely open there is no fedra
it wasn't uncommon for various Federal
qcs across the country to succumb to the
infected or the people themselves
remember in 2007 that Frank was fleeing
to Boston after he said the Baltimore qz
was totally gone now what happens next
plays out almost identical to the game
version a man faking an injury tries to
lure Joel and Ellie but Joel knows it's
a trap this was a tactic he used when he
was a hunter in the game the group that
has taken over Pittsburgh referred to
themselves as hunters and those they
hunt tourists but the Kansas City crew
referred to themselves more as Rebels or
revolutionaries who have taken over
fedra this group isn't to be confused
with the fireflies in the game we
uncover this node written by someone in
the hunters stating we don't need the
fireflies they seem to be a separate
more violent and extreme group than the
fireflies hitting the gas the truck hits
nail spikes and crashes into to a nearby
laundromat in the game it's a grocery
store and features a lot more enemies
partly because it leads to a large
gameplay segment in the show's version
there are only three men Joel orders
Ellie to hide behind a wall while he
takes care of two of them and injures
another but in the process almost gets
killed himself thankfully Ellie has that
gun but it's interesting to note that
she initially thought of using her
switchblade she creeps up behind the
assailant and shoots him a similar scene
appears in the game in the hotel segment
of Pittsburgh although in this one Ellie
flat out kills Joel's attacker it seems
as though the writers of the show are
trying to hold on to Ellie's innocence
having Joel finish the attacker off with
his knife the attacker refers to himself
as Brian the kid who says he can take
them to his mom where they can be fed
and taken in and trained it's an
interesting directorial choice to have
us not see him murdered rather hold the
frame on Ellie crying behind the wall as
we hear the gruesome sounds of a throat
being slit with their truck totaled and
the inability to carry their supplies
the two make off through the dangerous
Kansas city streets it's not long before
another group of rebels shout out for
Brian and his crew these guys seem to
have made their base set of former
ephedra Outpost we aren't sure exactly
how much time has passed since these
Rebels took over fedra but there's still
bullet holes and blood on the wall which
indicate it hasn't been a lot the game
is more definitive with a note stating
that this quote little revolution has
been going on for 14 months we also get
this Grim fedra poster which shows what
happens to anyone who's found to be a
traitor it's here we meet a woman known
simply as Kathleen the leader of this
revolutionary band it's pretty ironic
that a sign of federal rights are nailed
to the wall a group she fought to
overthrow for being too authoritarian
and yet now she rules in an even more
authoritarian fashion the same is true
of the extremism of the hunters in the
game with articles reading that fedra
captains were doused in gasoline and lit
on fire in front of her is a man who we
only know is her doctor a doctor who
acts actually delivered her she believes
he knows the whereabouts of several
members who once colluded with fedra
including a man named Henry who turned
in her brother which led to his death in
fact it's likely it was this very cell
where her brother was killed so this is
all very personal for Kathleen she's
looking for the people who killed her
brother now the doctor here wasn't
complicit in his death but he may know
where Henry is who was he pleads with
her knowing that she was wronged but
this violence needs to stop as she pulls
a gun on him she asks if he thinks she
won't do it and you can actually see him
shake his head he's known her her entire
life and it seems as though he knows she
won't do it and she puts down the gun
but as we'll see in the next scene it
only takes one change for her to muster
the courage to do it outside are the two
bodies of the men killed by Joel and a
third injured we can even see Brian's
father hovering over his body he even
got his own credit among the pack of
rebels is a man named Perry who's played
by the actor who portrayed Tommy in the
video game it doesn't take long for pair
paranoia to creep in maybe it was this
Henry guy who called in reinforcements
from outside the city Kathleen's told
that this injured Rebel won't survive
without a doctor luckily there's one
locked away but instead of bringing him
out Kathleen now has the motivation to
kill him later blaming the deaths of
these men on Henry she orders for the
city to be searched and not to stop
until Henry is found Joel and Ellie take
refuge in an abandoned bar as trucks
that say run and we the people scour the
streets their plan is to head to the
tallest building and get a good lay of
the land this is similar to what they
did in episode 2 where they saw the
infected roaming the streets of Boston
in the game their main goal is to reach
this bridge Ellie asked Joel if he's all
right for God's sake the man just
murdered three people one even up close
and personal with a knife and typical
Joel once again bottles his emotions
saying he's all right surprisingly Joel
isn't angry about Ellie withholding the
fact she had a gun perhaps because it
saved his life in the game it plays out
a bit differently Joel gets pissed off
at Ellie even though she saved his life
because she disobeyed his orders by not
staying where he told her I shut the
hell out of that guy huh and you just
hang back like I told you to well you're
glad I didn't right
I'm glad I didn't get my head blown off
by a goddamn kid the show version is the
opposite it's actually Joel who
apologizes for putting Ellie in a
situation where she had to shoot a man
as he tells her well you're glad I did
right
when you're just a kid
and you should know what it means but
the line I found it most intriguing in
this conversation was Ellie telling him
that this wasn't the first time she'd
hurt someone like that up until this
point in the show the only two people
she's hurt are the federal agent in
episode one and the infected in episode
3 which I don't really count and there
isn't anyone she really hurts in the
Left Behind DLC or American Dream Comics
so either the writers have made a change
from The Source material or we might see
something completely new in a flashback
that depicts just how violent Ellie can
be in a future episode remember in
episode 1 when Joel beats the fedra
agent to a pulp Ellie looks on
fascinated the most remarkable thing
about that moment is that when Ellie
watches him she is activated contrast
this with Sarah who sees her father
knock out Mrs Adler and her look is one
of complete shock so Ellie definitely
has this violent side to her even more
surprising is Joel letting Ellie keep
the gun even showing her the proper way
to grip it considering the [__] training
she got at fedrow in the game Joel
initially gives Ellie a rifle in their
battle against the hunters
you make every shot count later
exchanging it with a handgun about
something uh
a little more your size now Joel gives
her the gun on the conditions she
carries it in her bag but what does she
do as soon as his back is turned stashes
it instead in her jacket undoubtedly
this will come into play later on in the
season and her refusing Joel's orders
means that she's violated rule number
three rule three
you do what I say when I say it back at
the laundromat Kathleen inspects the
scene of Joel's crash Joel and Ellie are
nowhere to be found but Perry over here
has something to show her in a hidden
attic atop an abandoned building it
seems they found where Henry has been
hiding the attic is filled with crayon
drawings of Superman type characters
defeating fedra guards these two
characters represent Henry and his
little brother Sam the two characters
who pull weapons on Joel and Ellie at
the end of the episode I'll get more to
them near the end of the video Kathleen
notices that Their Food Supplies are low
and orders a doubling of the guards
around their Provisions but there seems
to be something more urgent on Perry's
mind he takes Kathleen to an underground
storage room where this giant crater lay
in the middle it almost erupts
suggesting that something is burrowing
underneath but what could it be what is
Goomba sentient fungus with shoes for
legs my best guess is that this is a
bloater the rarest most dangerous and
advanced of all the infected types this
kind was hinted at in episode 2. so
there aren't super infected that explode
fungus spores on you in the season
trailer we see one of these emerging
from underground so that's maybe what's
happening here to my knowledge Kansas
City does not have an underground Subway
so perhaps these creatures lurk in the
sewers or tunnel systems regardless
Kathleen says they'll deal with this
later her priority is Henry and I'm like
that [__] is crazy meanwhile Joel and
Ellie break into Kansas City's tallest
building one Kansas City Place a
42-story building on their Journey
upward Ellie asked Joel how he knew the
man who was hurt was pretending that's
because he Tess and Tommy were once like
them as he tells her he's played both
sides and this leads Ellie to the next
logical question has he killed innocent
people in both the game and show he
doesn't answer this question however the
game takes it a little bit more
light-hearted so uh you kill a lot of
innocent people
ah
don't take that as a yes they only make
it up 33 floors before Joel is pooped
the man is 56 after all oh yes 56 years
old [__] it Harkens back to Tess
complaining about the stairs back in
episode 2. should I climb into
temps with our knees see how you feel
before heading to bed jol lays out some
glass in front of the door like some
elaborate Home Alone trap and the shoes
on the other foot when Ellie refuses to
open up about her personal life when
Joel asks him what she meant about
hurting someone not being her first time
he reiterates that it isn't fair having
to deal with this at her age and
unfortunately dealing with it doesn't
get better with age we also learned that
Joel's hearing is busted on the right
side luckily from having shot from that
side over and over again but I'm not
exactly sure if this will come and play
any part in the plot going forward and
who could forget a nice bedtime pun
before bed did you know diarrhea is
hereditary
it runs in your jeans I
it's one of the first genuine moments
between these two where they get to
share a laugh but that's soon to be
short-lived sometime passes and Joel and
Ellie wake up to guns pointed at their
face as if their day couldn't get any
better this is Henry and his little
brother Sam or at least their brothers
in the game there are a few key
differences to note here Sam is
considerably younger in the show than in
the game with the game version stating
that he's almost Ellie's age of 14.
their first meeting occurs while hiding
from the hunters and Henry and Sam
attack thinking their enemies but it
soon becomes apparent they have the same
goals in mind it'll be interesting to
see how the show continues the story
from here in the game the two pairs
joined forces to pass the hunter guard
post at night to make it to a military
radio station will this play out like in
the game or have the writers concocted
something completely different but for
now we're left with this Cliffhanger hey
Cliff ears but what did you think of
episode four I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram acting story YT until next
time remember why are all those pages
stuck together uh